bonjour courage chers nous merci de
répondre à nos questions l'émir du qatar
appel au dialogue et à la désescalade
hassan rohani a lui aussi tenu des
propos plus modéré qu'au début de la
crise née de la mort de qassem suleimani
est ce qu'on peut y voir des signes
encourageants des signes d'apaisement
bonjour merci d'invités oui on peut voir
des signes des signes encourageants
perçus comme vous avez vu des débuts en
fait une fois que les américains ont tué
ce général iranien par l'anact
assassinats des iraniens ont riposté
mais de manière très très mesuré ils ont
même près de le prévenu les irakiens
quelques heures avant en disant qu'il
faut pas qu'il y ait de blessés où il
faut patiner de mort à l'amérique à
quetta et les deux camps on appelait à
une désescalade ce qu'on peut en tirer
comme conclusion première c'est que ni
les américains ni les iraniens souhait
de la guerre ils essaient de s'en sortir
on attaque on fait des petites attaques
mais aucun des deux camps ne souhaite la
guerre il ya eu des nouvelles
roquettes qui ont été tirées sur des
bases militaires en irak on a vu dans le
sujet de françois xavier lambert l'irak
ou le plus haut dignitaire chiite
l'ayatollah ali c'est al sistani a
condamné ceux qui font de son pays il y
le terrain de leur affrontement quelle
est la stratégie de téhéran vis-à-vis de
son voisin irakien alors que sur les
vestiaires domicile déjà on sait pas
exactement qui attirait la stratégie de
l'iran en fait c'est plutôt il faut voir
ce que souhaitent les pirates
l'irak ne souhaite pas qu'il y ait une
guerre par procuration sur son
territoire que les américains et les
iraniens ne se bat pas sur son
territoire et ils ont demandé à la suite
de l'assassinât du général soliman et
ils ont demandé aux irakiens à l'armée
américaine de quitter le pays
l'amérique dans le grande nation
démocratique évidemment ils ont nous
n'avons que faire ce que vous dites vous
de ce que vous souhaitez nous allons
rester sur place
l'iphone a cité cette année appelle
aussi à la paix le problème c'est que
c'est ce que les américains vont sortir
de l'irak ou pas et même s'il sort parce
que ça va changer quelque chose
le ce qui va se passer si les américains
quittent le pays et que les iraniens ne
sont pas ne reste pas très influent là
bas il y aura un vide et se vident
risque d'être rempli à nouveau ardèche
où d'autres d'autres ou d'autres groupes
terroristes
l'iran a promis de punir les militaires
responsables de la destruction de
l'avion ukrainien à quoi est ce qu'on
peut s'attendre
sachant qu'il y aurait également eu hier
devant le parlement iranien
le remplaçant de qassem suleimani au
salami qui s'est exprimé à huit clos un
césar oui il c'est excellent s'était
exprimé au parlement il a même il a dit
qu'il souhaitait en fait être dans
l'avion il souhaitait être un marqueur
dans cet avion il préférait être martyrs
dans cet avion ou moins denses et à
millions puisque qu'il y ait ces gens
qu'ils soient tous en mémoire par cette
faute commise par rapport à mes gardiens
de la révolution ils le reconnaissent
la question la plus importante c'est de
savoir est ce qu ils ont fait exprès ou
pas je ne pense pas il ya une faute
la faute la faute la plus importante
c'est que une fois qu'ils ont tiré les
missiles et qu'ils ont riposté contre
les américains il aurait dû fermer le
l'espace aérien iranien
ils ne l'ont pas fait et apparemment de
ce que disent les gardiens de la
révolution c'est que la personne qui
devait appuyer sur le bouton pensé que
c'était un avion ennemi et a décidé de
lancer un missile antiaérien et c'est à
nyon a malheureusement été abattu avec
beaucoup de binationaux canadien iranien
jeu proprement parler très bien passé
j'ai vécu au canada je connais un peu la
situation
mais c'est une faute mais qui sera puni
vous savez il ya quelques années il ya
eu les américains qui ont descendu à un
avion iranien sur le pôle bercy
quelques années après vous avez eu un
avion au malaisien qui a été abattu par
des russes ou les écluses ukrainien et
aucune suite n'est aucune punition c'est
que l'iran comme les états unis ne vont
pas reconnaître ne vont pas reconnaître
ils vont dire qu'il n'ya pas eu de fond
et que c'était c'était un accident
il n'y a pas encore de preuves un avérée
concernant le vol malev dont vous venez
de parler mais pour revenir sur canada
vous qui avez vécu au canada on a vu
également le premier ministre justin
trudeau qui a assuré lors d'une
cérémonie d'hommage aux nombreuses
victimes canadiennes que justice sera
faite
qu'est ce que ça implique pour les
futures relations entre ottawa et teyran
alors justice se rater dans les
relations entre le canada et plus
beaucoup plus allié des états unis et
écoute ce que disent les américains ont
fait des ans vécu au canada je peux vous
dire bon ca c'est un peuple c'est un
peuple qui
qui est très démocratique qui est très
libérale qui souhaitent la paix la
justice la justice qui sera fait ce sera
sûrement des compresses des
compensations financières
premièrement il faut qu'ils aient un
rapatriement des corps de ces
binationaux au canada pour que leurs
proches puissent puissent faire leur
honneur lauriane et il faut aussi
également ils ont demandé en fait le
canada a demandé le canada a demandé à
ce que les familles des proches puissent
aller au canada pour puis pour pouvoir
être proche de leur famille et des gens
qui ont été décidées dans ce dans cette
attaque
merci à une compensation financière sûr
et certain est-ce que l'iran va accepter
ou pas ou est ce qu'il y aura des avoirs
iraniens qui seront gelé quelques pas et
qui sont saisis par les canadiens on
sait pas encore merci courant charme ou
d'avoir répondu à nos questions sur arte
france ne plus taire